- Le verglas qui a tout enrobé à
Montréal, le matin du 5 janvier,
a fait au moins un heureux :
celui qui pilote les essaisdu Rd
et la gare centrale.
JULIEN HUREL, dir. principal,
systèmes transport, CDPQ Infra
- On a souhaité effectivement
faire rouler un véhicule et voir
les limites de l'exploitation
dans ces conditions-là.
- Et le train est tombé en panne
au bout d'environ 10 kilomètres,
entre le pont Champlain.
- Une fois que le fil est
recouvert de glace, la glace
agit comme isolantetet il y a
perte de contact électrique
entre le fil qui conduit
l'électricité et le pantographe.
- Et les équipes avaient fait
exprès de ne pas déglacer
les caténaires, selon
le protocole prévu.
- Qui consiste à faire rouler
des véhicules deiiière
régulière pour justement
empêcher l'accumulation
de glace sur le fil, sur le fil
de contact. Et en plus de cela,
on équipe certains véhicules,
pas tous, d'un grattoir.
- Ce qui s'est passé à Ottawa,
avec six jours d'interruption
sue e e partie du réseau
de train léger, serait en partie
dû à une mauvaise gestion
des véhicules pendant l'épisode
de verglas, selon cet expert.
- Parce que la fréquence était
pasesesez grande, la glace
s'est accumulée, et elle s'est
accumulée à une vitesse
rapide et continue.
- Mais le système automatisé
du REM montréalais sera-t-il
à l'abri de problèmes
similaires?
- Il n'est pas moins vulnérable,
il est simplement plus flexible.
C'est-à-dire que si vous devez
aller chercher un conducteur
à minuit pour justement répondre
à un épisode de pluie
verglaçante, c'est un petit peu
c c c compliqué que d'appuyer
sur 3-4 boutons pour sortir un
véhicule de la zone de remisage.
- Lors du test du 5 janvier, le
REM est reparti après quelques
minutes d'immobilisation. Mais
en cas de pannes prolongées, il
faudra se rabattre sur les bus
de Longueuil, au risque de miner
la confiance des usagers.
SARAH DOYON, Trajectoire Québec
- Si ça arrive trop souvent,
bien, on va avoir aussi
un réseau de bus à Longueuil
qui sera pas fiable, puis
finalement, si ni le R
ni le réseau de bus sont
fiables, bien, on va perdre
des usagers, malheureusement.
- L'ouverture de la section
Rive-Sud du REM a été reportée
à ce printemps, après
les tests hivernaux.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa